how do you train chess these days
what's uh
do you practice do you do deliberate
practice i mean you're in this tough
position because you're also a creator
and educator and entertainer
so
do you try to put in time of like daily
practice
i don't train chess anymore when i'm
focusing on creating i do if i'm
preparing for a tournament but back in
the day i would train very tournament
very seriously for tournaments and
the way it would work is i do opening
preparation for a specific tournament
because that's when you really need to
have those lines memorized and you could
also prepare for specific opponents and
i would do tactics to make sure i stay
sharp so those are the two things i
would do every single day for a
tournament and then mix up the rest with
like maybe some end games maybe some
positional chess so what is tactics uh
preparation looks like do you do like a
puzzle
like uh like a random puzzle thing
yeah i would just train puzzles for at
least like 30 to 60 minutes or books and
sometimes you were
and there's different kinds of puzzles
one you could train for pattern
recognition where you're supposed to go
through them very quickly and that's
just so that when you're playing the
game if your mind is tired it's still
keeping
track of things a little bit more easily
and then there's where you're practicing
your combination and those sometimes
take like 20 minutes to find because you
have to just calculate a lot and it's
more like making sure that you've
trained with that muscle but andrea is
actually very good at finding ways to
balance and still study while also doing
content yeah so what you're able to do
both
that's the hard thing i was getting very
irritated with content because i'm very
competitive i don't like playing chess
if i'm losing and if you're talking and
entertaining you're going to be losing
more games than winning so then i
started doing more training streams
where i'd bring on my coach and one of
the things that i wanted to add to alex
is training repertoire so i do i would
do daily puzzles every time um i'm
streaming which helped me a lot even if
it's like there's this thing on
chess.com called puzzle rush where you
have three minutes and you just do
puzzle after puzzle where they get
incrementally harder
um and it's just a really good way to
build your pattern recognition
especially when you're rusty so i would
do that until i hit a high score and i
wouldn't play any blitz until i hit the
score that i want
but that's kind of more like the fun
part of chess studying um the very
important one is actually analyzing your
losses and your tournament games
and first you sit and you look through
your mistake yourself and try to see if
you can find the better moves and then
that's why you knew we would check over
with a computer to see if you're right
um so game analysis is also very
important which i try to do remember to
give a shout out i listened to a couple
of episodes of the perpetual chess
podcast
which is pretty pretty good but what
with the whatever i listen to i remember
the per it's um
i think they really focus on
like teaching people
how to train yeah how to play how to
train all that kind of stuff uh they do
like uh
yeah i'm looking now adult improver so
basically
like how do regular noobs get better at
chess yeah uh one of the things they one
of the person that said i think he's the
grandmaster but he said uh
to maximize the amount of time you spend
every day of like
basically as you were saying like
suffering so like
you it's not about the like you should
be thinking you should be doing
calculating so it's the opposite of what
magnus said like you should be doing a
lot of time it doesn't matter what the
puzzle is or whatever the hell you're
doing but you should be like doing that
difficult calculation that's how you get
better yeah it really depends what
you're training because i used to think
the same but it depends what you're
you're at because if you're doing the
really difficult puzzles you're training
for like visualization and calculating
more moves ahead than you typically
would which maybe you wouldn't get into
that as often in a regular game because
typically you run into like three to
four tactics which are actually the
easier and more fun ones to solve so it
really depends and on top of that as a
hobbyist your motivation is very
different than when you're playing from
a young age and have pretty high
competitive ambition and
a lot of people who are new to chess
you could basically work on anything and
still improve
so if you're focusing on something you
like you're probably going to stick to
it more and be more consistent which i
think is more helpful long term
you